يدخل العالم ثوره علميه جديده عنوانها
عضلات صناعيه تفوق قوه العضلات البشريه
بسبعه 10 مرات هذه ثوره قادها علماء
كوريون نجحوا في تطوير هذه العضلات
باستخدام الياف المصنوعه من ماده جديده
لتكون الاختراق الابرز في عالم القوه
الصناعيه الممثله للبشر
التوقعات الاوليه لهذا الانجاز تذهب
الامكانيه استخدام هذه العضلات بمختلف
الصناعات لا سيما روبوتات واعضاء الجسم
الداخليه للصناعيه حيث يتوقع ان تحل مكان
الاجهزه الميكانيكيه لروبوتات والتي تنجع
الحركه الجسم غير طبيعيه وغير مماثله لجسم
الانسان
[تصفيق]
والله هو مجال
البوستات الجديده
دول شرق اسيا بشكل كبير قوي المجال ده
بشكل عام بيعتمد على الاطراف التعويضيه
بشكل كبير وازاي نعرف نستخدم الرباط
التعويضيه وبالنسبه كبيره هو دائما بيدخل
في ثلاث اماكن اول حاجه هي الالكترونكس
الجينيرينج بعد كده الميكانيكا الانجري
والكنترول دايما بيكون استخدام التكنولوجي
ان احنا بنحاول نعتمد على سين سورز
وحساسات موجوده عشان تحس بالنضات وبعد كده
نقدر نحرك بها الاجزاء الميكانيكيه وفي
نفس الوقت بيكون في كنترول يونتس دي بتبقى
وحده مرمجيه بنكتب فيها الاكواد الخاصه
بالتحكم بالعضلات دي العضلات دي معظم
الاوقات كانت بتبقى عباره عن اجزاء
ميكانيكيه زي مواتير او اجزاء حركيه
بتعتمد على الكهرباء المميز جدا في
الابتكار ده اللي هي بقت بتعتمد على
الحراره وفي نفس الوقت هي عباره عن الياف
والالياف دي نقدر نجمع منها الالياف اكبر
بكثير تحاكي العضلات الحقيقيه
هذا بالنسبه للروبوتات والاعضاء الصناعيه
هل يمكن ان نذهب ابعد من ذلك بكثير ان
نطور هذه التقنيه في عضله في الجسم عضله
حيه لكي تكون ب 17 مره اقوى من العضله
الاصليه ده حقيقي دائما لما احنا بنحاول
نطور التكنولوجيا بتاعه الاجزاء التعويضيه
كنا بنحاول في الاول خالص ان احنا نحاول
نعملها بالشكل الطبيعي او بالشكل التقليدي
بنفس القوه البشريه لكن بدانا احنا عندنا
القدره استخدام الزكاه الاصطناعي ان احنا
نعمل سيناريشن ونعمل محاكاه نقدر نوصل
لاضعاف القوه دي لان انا فعلا ان احنا
نستخدم اكثر من مجموعه من الالياف
المختلفه بحيث ان احنا نوصل لدرجه زي 10
اضعاف و17 ضعف من القوه الطبيعيه وده
موجود كمان في التكنولوجيا الهكسوس كلتون
اللي احنا بنحاول نعمل اجزاء كمان خارجيه
مش داخليه بس الجسم الانسان بحيث انها
تساعده انه نعرف يحمل اوزان كبيره جدا ما
كانش يقدر يحملها في الشكل العادي بتاعه
محمد ده متخصص في تطبيق الروبوت بتاعه هل
يفهم من ان هذه العضله في حركه داخل جسم
الانسان ستكون اكثر مرونه واك السياقا
واكثر طبيعيه مع حركه الجسم مقارنه
بالعضلات الروبوتيه الميكانيكيه
ما بتعتمدش على باتريز ما بتعتمدش على
كهربا هي بتعتمد على درجه الحراره بس
فيحصل قدر يحصل لها انتجريشن او دمج داخل
جسم الانسان بشكل اسهل بكثير جدا عن الشكل
الاول للكهرباء او للمواتير وفي نفس الوقت
باستخدام حاجه زي دي تقدر في نفس تبقى
عضويه نعرف نحطها جوه العضو من غير ما
تاثر عليه ما يبقاش في اي تشويش اي
الكترونكس او اي باور بياثر على جسم
الانسان فاستخدام ابتكار زي اللي بتتكرار
العظيم ده ان احنا نعرف نستخدم درجه
الحراره دي هتفرق كثير جدا وفي نفس الوقت
بما انها الياف والالياف الدقيقه جدا
استخدام الصناعي والسمليشن نقدر ان احنا
نعلي من قدرتها بشكل كبير